for three hours starting at noon eastern
book tv's in depth the first sunday of
every month on c-span 2.
up next former new york times foreign
correspondent stephen kinser presents a
dual biography of brothers john foster
dulles former secretary of state and
alan dulles former director of the cia
this event from the harvard bookstore in
cambridge massachusetts is about an hour
and 20 minutes
[Applause]
thank you so much it's wonderful to be
here with all of you
i always love being in a bookstore and
especially an independent bookstore like
this one
those of us who write books rely
entirely on places like this
not just for selling our books but for
the inspiration that we hope
leads us to write them so i i really
appreciate this opportunity and i always
encourage people to patronize their
independent bookstores and
go online and figure out what books you
want then come here and buy them
i should add
that lately i've left boston university
just as a minor correction i'm now uh at
the watson
institute for international studies at
brown university which is a wonderful
place for me to do research and uh work
with some wonderful professors and and
great students
um and these are professors and students
who like everyone else in america
have largely forgotten
or never knew about
the dulles brothers
during the period when i was immersing
myself in the lives of these
extraordinary brothers i came to realize
how remarkable has been their fall from
public consciousness
at the height of the cold war when they
were in power in the 1950s
these were immensely powerful figures
they could make and break governments
and they did
probably every literate human being on
the face of the earth knew the name
dulles
now
the dulles brothers are largely
forgotten
i realized this while i was writing the
book because several times when friends
of mine asked me uh what are you working
on and i'd say i'm writing a book about
dallas
they would look at me and say the
airport
the dulles brothers approach to the
world did not work out well for the
united states
and i think that's part of the reason
why we've airbrushed them out of our
history they tell us some things about
ourselves that we really don't like to
see or hear
as a result
we've allowed them to fade from history
i think
nations like individuals like to think
of themselves as good we all have a
positive self-image of ourselves and
those episodes that contradict our good
self image are ones that we tend to like
to minimize and forget we like to
pretend they never happened
this to a certain degree has happened
with the dulles brothers
and i figured that out when in the
course of writing this book
i
found the video clip
of president john f kennedy
opening dulles airport
after john foster dulles died in 1959
president eisenhower announced
immediately that this big super airport
that was being built out at chantilly
virginia would be named
dulles airport
soon afterward john f kennedy came into
office
kennedy didn't like this idea john
foster dulles was a crusty old cold
warrior and kennedy wanted to present a
different kind of an image so he let it
be known that the airport was not going
to be named dulles it would probably be
called chantilly international there was
some talk that it might be named after
george marshall
but there was an immediate pushback
eisenhower and alan dulles who was still
alive put a lot of pressure on kennedy
and finally
he relented and he agreed to name the
airport after john foster dallas and in
this video clip you see him giving his
speech and then he pulls aside a curtain
and there is that giant bust of john
foster dulles that stands in the center
of dulles airport
now those of you who have been through
dulles airport might ask yourself what
bus is at
i asked myself that and
of course made a special trip to dulles
during one of my uh travels uh in order
to go look at the bust
which is placed right at the center of
the airport in front of the reflecting
pool that the architect aerosaren had
designed as a way of calming the
turbulent spirits of stressed out
travelers
so all you have to do is find the
reflecting pool
and there's the statue so where's the
reflecting pool
there is no reflecting pool i asked the
security guards where where is it they
don't know any reflecting pool okay well
then where's the bust of john foster
dulles
some of the security guards had no idea
where the bust was and some of them had
no idea who john foster dulles was
it's a long story but with the help of
the
metropolitan washington airports
authority
i finally tracked down
the bust of john foster dallas
it is in a closed conference room
opposite baggage claim number three
this really reflects what has happened
to the reputation of the dulles brothers
it's my desire with this book to bring
them back to life in a way that shows
how influential they were
but i really have another goal with this
book it's a biography
of these two remarkable figures but it's
more than that
i'm trying to use the framework of
biography
to ask a larger question which is
why does the united states act the way
that it does in the world
why are we like this
why is it that every time there's some
kind of a crisis or confrontation or
upheaval in
bhutan or bilis or bangladesh or burundi
or bolivia
we feel like we have to take sides oh
who do we want to crush who do we want
to support what are we going to do
the idea that we're going to sit back
and say well the bolivians or the
bhutanese or the bangladeshis have a
problem and they're going to go resolve
it and we'll just wait and see what
unfolds
this was inconceivable to the dulles
brothers and i think that's a strain
that's woven into our body politic
americans don't have this idea that we
should just observe the world and watch
it unfold we have to be involved
everywhere
in fact uh the dulles brothers were
founders of the council on foreign
relations and while i was researching
that aspect of the book
i realized that the council on foreign
relations actually has a slogan i hadn't
realized this but if you look on their
magazine foreign affairs you'll see they
have a logo and the logo is a flying
horse it's the pegasus figure
and then there's a little scribble in
the circle which i always thought was
just chicken scratch i never really paid
attention to it
but i looked at it more closely as i was
working on this book and i see that it's
it's a latin word
and the word is
ubiqui means everywhere
that is the answer to these great
questions where does the united states
have vital interests where must the
united states be involved where do we
have to have operations underway all the
time
everywhere
that was the
concept that guided the dulles brothers
and the foreign policy establishment
that ruled this country really for the
first half of the 20th century right
into the 1960s what's remarkable about
this elite is how small it was in those
days american foreign policy was really
the province of a very small group of
people they all went to the same schools
they were all white protestant males
they were all wealthy they all worked
for the same law firms and the same
investment banks they all had the same
outlook on the world
it was a very inbred group and they all
shared the same view of the world
the dulles brothers were perhaps the
ultimate exemplars of that view
now
in my book i don't just talk about the
dulles brothers as political figures i'm
trying to understand them as individuals
and that's why i take their story all
the way back to early childhood and
before
the dulles brothers were really
vessels of american history
so let me tell you a little bit about
the forces
that shaped them because i think these
are also forces that shaped our country
the dulles brothers really
are us
we are them
they did not hijack america or american
foreign policy they did what we wanted
and i think that might be one of the
reasons we've forgotten them if we
really want to find
who's to blame for many of the
crises that the dulles brothers left
behind
rather than point a finger at the
picture of the dulles brothers on the
wall
maybe looking in the mirror would be a
little more effective
so what were these forces that shaped
these remarkable brothers
well the first one was
missionary calvinism
the dulles brothers grew up in a
parsonage their father was a clergyman
their grandfather was a clergyman their
great-grandfather was a clergyman many
of their uncles and great uncles were
clergymen and also missionaries their
grandfather for example went off to
india to convert the heathens
and at home over dinner they were always
having missionaries who were on their
way back from china or back from the
middle east so they were immersed in the
missionary ethos
this was not uh just a
bland or a heterodox form of
christianity it was a very specific form
and it had two essential principles
the first is
the world is
made up of good forces and evil forces
and the second is
christians do not have the right to sit
home
and hope that good triumphs over evil
they have to go out in the world
and convert the unconverted and bring
them to the light
if you don't do that
you are not fulfilling
the purpose for which god has placed you
on earth now if you believe that about
religion
it is a very short step
to believing the same thing about
geopolitics you believe that governments
and political movements in the world are
either good
or evil
and as an american you cannot sit home
and watch this conflict unfold you must
go out in the world and be sure that
good triumphs over evil
this is a view that's actually different
from the world view that people hold in
many other parts of the world and many
other cultures
in much of the world
people grow up with the idea that
all individuals and all governments are
made up of good and evil impulses and
these come out in different proportions
depending on circumstances
the dallas brothers did not believe this
the world really was divided uh between
the forces of light
and the forces of darkness
so this was one of the key
forces that shaped the dulles brothers
the second was their upbringing
at the very pinnacle of the american
elite
so these boys grew up in the town of
watertown new york up on the shores of
lake ontario it's a kind of a playground
for the new york rich
and their father was the pastor there
every morning during the summer time
they would get up early and take a cold
shower the only kind their father
reverend dulles permitted uh
they would say their prayers with their
father's guidance sing a couple of hymns
and then they were free to rush down to
the shores of the lake
where their two
beloved older relatives were waiting to
take them out on little boats to stalk
the wily smallmouth bass
uh who were those two relatives these
were the two figures that were the
dominant influences in the lives of the
young boys as they grew up
one of them was their grandfather
john watson foster
he was a former secretary of state
he had been secretary of state in the
1890s
and in fact
he was the first secretary of state to
preside over the american overthrow of a
foreign government
uh it was he who was secretary of state
when the united states launched its
operation to overthrow the government of
hawaii and bring hawaii into the united
states
so
the family got into the regime change
business even before the dulles brothers
were born
grandfather foster as they called him
had been a pioneer who had tamed the
wilderness and gone out west an exemplar
of uh
the idea of manifest destiny
think of how
this span of time passed in the space
just from the grandfather to the
grandsons john watson foster campaigned
for abraham lincoln
and his grandsons john foster dulles and
alan dulles projected american power all
over the world in the nuclear age
the other figure that was with them on
their daily fishing outings
was
robert lansing robert lansing was also
secretary of state he was secretary of
state during world war one
so
you had these
figures
who themselves embodied the idea of
america
at least as they understood it and they
transferred to the dulles brothers
not just the ideals and beliefs of the
american ruling class but its style and
its vocabulary and its perceptions
grandfather foster as they called him
was so besotted and infatuated with his
grandsons
he found it wasn't enough to spend
summers with them up in watertown
he wanted to bring them down to
washington dc to live with him for some
months during the winter
and they did they spent a number of uh
their winters uh at the foster mansion
on the next dupont circle in washington
there they were having dinner every
night with william howard taft grover
cleveland woodrow wilson andrew carnegie
bernard baruch these were their dinner
partners when they were 10 years old
they of course didn't participate in the
dinner conversations
but they absorbed so much during those
long evenings and this was part of their
training to join the american elite
in fact i discovered that alan dulles
who started attending these dinners when
he was about eight years old had a
wonderful habit and it's particularly
interesting when you realize that he
became the head of the cia at the age of
eight years old after these dinners were
over he would go upstairs and unlike his
brother who would just go to sleep
he would go to his desk and write little
reports about what he thought of each of
the people at the dinner
and
not only what they said but what he
thought they really meant so he was
already into this psychology in fact he
later wrote that uh the fishing trips
that he took were very influential in
pushing him towards the career that he
had in espionage and covert action
because he said you catch the fish then
you play him and you move him and you
try to slowly reel him in until he gets
to the point where he's almost grateful
to be caught
this was the lesson that alan dallas
took from his fishing trips when he was
a young boy
so that became the second force that
shaped the dulles brothers their
introduction to the highest levels of
the american elite at a very young age
the third force came later in the dulles
brothers
lives
both of them went to work
for
the unique
corporate law firm of sullivan and
cromwell in fact john foster dulles the
older brother was the managing partner
of sullivan and cromwell for 30 years
alan dulles also worked there for
decades
uh now sullivan and cromwell
it was an old normal law firm
they could draft a contract for you if
you wanted or even represent you in a
courtroom but that was not what they
existed to do
sullivan and cromwell had a specialty
and their specialty was
pressuring small and weak countries to
do what big american corporations wanted
them to do
that's why
almost every big american multinational
corporation
hired sullivan and cromwell and
in effect the dulles brothers to defend
them
john foster dulles had just gone to work
for the company as a young clerk fifty
dollars a month
which of course grandfather foster
generously supplemented
when he was given his first assignment
and it's a classic one because it shows
exactly what
sullivan and cromwell did
an american agricultural products
company had hired sullivan and cromwell
to do
exactly the kind of thing that sullivan
and cromwell was famous for
this company wanted to export flour to
guyana
but guyana had tariffs in order to
protect the domestic agricultural
industry
so sullivan and cromwell was asked by
this american company to see if they
could make those tariffs go away
john foster dulles got the job
he went to guyana
uh he made the guyanese leaders an offer
they couldn't refuse
not sure it included a horse's head but
we don't know uh and when he came home
there were no more tariffs on american
flour coming into guyana
it was only a few years after that that
foster dulles was given another job that
really reflected what sullivan and
cromwell could do uh that company that
law firm represented most of the
american corporations that were active
in cuba almost all the big american
sugar companies and fruit companies that
were active in cuba plus the owners of
the cuban railroad lines and the owners
of cement companies and several mines in
cuba were all
sullivan and cromwell clients
in the second decade
of the 20th century
an election was held in cuba and the
incumbent conservative party which had
been happy to give to american
corporations
everything they wanted was defeated
the liberal party won the election but
the conservatives refused to give up
office so the liberals began a rebellion
in order to force uh the country to
observe the result of the election
the american corporations were terrified
by this because the liberal party was
committed to land reform and of course
the way they were going to get the land
they wanted to give out to peasants was
they were going to get it from the big
american sugar companies and the fruit
companies and they wanted to erect a
tariff wall around cuba to promote
domestic industry so in short the
liberal party was a nightmare terror
figure for american corporate interests
represented by sullivan and cromwell
john foster dulles was given the job
figure out what to do about this problem
the next morning he got on the train in
new york and he went to washington d.c
he went to see the secretary of state
who happened to be
uncle burt
he told uncle bert
we should send two warships to cuba
we should both go to the eastern end of
the island where the rebellion's going
on one on the north one on the south
and then they should land marines and
put down this rebellion
one day later the warships were
dispatched
they did go to cuba
six thousand marines just sparked
they crushed the liberal rebellion and
they remained in occupied cuba for the
following six years
this was the kind of thing that the
dulles brothers were used to doing that
was their job that's what they did for a
living
and that's what made sullivan and
cromwell such a desirable firm for
american multinational business
this was again the third force that
shaped the dallas brothers
it gave them the idea
that
the interests of big american
corporations
and the interests of the united states
were the same thing
this was the way they saw the world as
private lawyers and they took
that world view with them
into office
so again you see them being shaped by
missionary calvinism
uh the ruling elite of the united states
into which they were born
and
the idea of american corporate power
now
in the
early 1950s
both of the dulles brothers became very
active in washington john foster dulles
was the
principal foreign policy adviser to
dwight eisenhower when he ran for
president
uh alan dulles got into the cia in a
secondary position even before
eisenhower came to office
after eisenhower's election in
1952
he named these two brothers to the top
positions in his government john foster
dulles became secretary of state
and his younger brother alan dulles
became director of the cia
this was the first and only time in
history
that siblings controlled the overt and
covert sides of american foreign policy
they functioned essentially like
two jaws of a serpent not organically
connected but always working towards the
same goal
now
the dulles brothers and sullivan and
cromwell thrived and in fact john foster
dulles was said to be the highest paid
lawyer in the united states
because of their success
in protecting the interests of the big
american corporations that were their
clients
they were able to guarantee their
clients if you have interests in a
foreign country and you hire us
your interests will be safe
and it was that gold standard that kept
the dulles brothers so rich and kept
sullivan and cromwell uh so desirable
for american corporations
in 1951
the dulles brothers suffered two
terrible blows
blows of the kind they had never
suffered before or ever even imagined
the first one happened in guatemala
the elected government of guatemala
under president jokobo arbenz with the
approval of the elected democratic
congress of guatemala
decided on a land reform act
that land reform act has its principal
clause
those who own huge amounts of land
and aren't using most of it
have to sell the unused land
to the government and the government
will then slice up this land and give
little parcels out to
landless peasants
the biggest land owner in guatemala was
united fruit the banana company
it had over half a million acres of
unused land
i think one of the real reasons they
wanted to keep that land was they didn't
want any other banana company in there
to compete with them
so
this land reform act was passed the
dulles brothers protested vigorously so
did the united states government but
there was nothing the dulles brothers
could do as private lawyers they had to
sit back and watch one of their most
important clients suffer a terrible blow
in guatemala it wasn't just the united
fruit company
united fruit had two other subsidiary or
associated companies that helped
solidify their control over guatemala
they owned irka the central american
railroad company that owned all the rail
lines in guatemala and they owned the
electric company that produced all the
electricity in guatemala all three of
these companies were sullivan and
cromwell clients they were clients of
the dulles brothers um and so was the
schroeder bank which was the uh
financial agent for all of these
companies in fact allen dulles sat on
the board of the schroeder bank and of
course both brothers were stockholders
in the united fruit company
so in 1951
they had to face
the directors of the united fruit
company which had been a client of
sullivan and cromwell for more than half
a century and say
we failed
you're losing your land in guatemala
and there's nothing we can do
the dulles brothers did not like having
to give a message like that
they never forgot
this but just as their rage at arpens
was rising they suffered another blow in
the same year and that came from the
other side of the world in iran
there also a nationalist regime had come
to power as part of the
surge of
nationalist movements that emerged after
the second world war
under prime minister mohammad musa deck
the government of iran with the
unanimous vote of the
iranian parliament voted to nationalize
the iranian oil industry
that industry was owned by one company
the anglo-iranian oil company
and that oil company's financial agent
was the schroeder bank also represented
by the dulles brothers and as i said uh
it was a company of which alan dulles
was a director
they had to go to the schroeder bank and
say we failed you again
we couldn't protect your interest in
iran
there was nothing they could do as
private lawyers but they bore a very
deep grudge
against these two leaders
they came into office at the beginning
of 1953
and their very first project which they
started even before eisenhower was
inaugurated they couldn't even wait for
their first day at work was
overthrow musa deck in iran
uh
by august of that year they had
accomplished it he was gone and that was
the end of democracy in iran
uh 10 months after that
president arbenz of guatemala suffered
the same fate
so those were the first two
monsters
that the dulles brothers
went out to destroy
my book has a the main section about
their period in office
it's called six monsters
uh i use that word uh
because i'm taking it from a wonderful
speech that was given by
secretary of state john quincy adams on
independence day in 1821 he made that
famous statement
america does not go abroad in search of
monsters to destroy
but the dulles brothers did
they saw
these monsters as the face of evil the
evil that they had seen in the
antichrist and the
evil that they saw in bolshevism
they naturally equated both of these
leaders uh arbenz in guatemala and
masadek
in iran as tools of the soviets
this wasn't true
but
that's the way the world looked to them
in fact i found an interesting document
written by the ambassador from brazil
to the united states during the period
when the dulles brothers were
overthrowing
our benz in guatemala this ambassador
came to see john foster dallas and he
said to him how do you know
that the land reform program in
guatemala was ordered by the kremlin
and he says in his note dulles told me
it is true that we have no evidence but
we are proceeding on the assumption that
it must be so
that was the way they saw the world
so the first two monsters that the
dulles brothers went out to slay in the
world were two
against whom they had a deep grudge
from their days as private lawyers
now by the time we got to the
middle of 1954
both of those monsters were gone
one of the things that i understood as i
began researching the secret history of
the dulles brothers
is that what i knew and i think what
most of us know about the 1950s
is fundamentally mistaken we think of it
as an age of peace
in fact we were at a continual war the
entire 1950s we didn't know it at the
time we didn't see it only now can we
look back and understand
how the dulles brothers never finished
one operation without beginning another
now they were not the kind of people who
like to sit back and observe and reflect
they always wanted to be in action
and that's why the subtitle of this book
is john foster dulles allen dulles and
their secret world war
so in 1954
uh with
uh the first two projects finished the
dulles brothers went out against their
next monster
that was ho chi minh in vietnam
it had been pretty easy to brush aside
our bands pretty easy to brush aside
musa deck
wouldn't be any problem to take care of
ho chi minh i guess they figured
in 1954 a conference was held in geneva
at which uh the big powers came together
to decide the future of vietnam
it was actually held at the same time
that the french suffered their epic
defeat at tien bien fu after that defeat
the french
with great pain realized that
they couldn't win the war that ho chi
minh was immensely powerful and
immensely popular
and that therefore although they didn't
like it
they were just going to have to accept
the fact that they couldn't hold on in
vietnam and they were quitting
winston churchill
had the same idea he came to the
conclusion as he told the dulles
brothers in a wonderful phrase that as
you certainly expect from a person who's
been through so many victories and
defeats in war
the loss of the fortress must be faced
essentially what he was saying is we
hate it but he won the war so let's move
on to the next battlefield and
not try to fight a battle that's not
winnable
but john foster dulles refused to accept
this
uh he believed that he could do what the
french and the british and the japanese
had all failed to do which was
take over vietnam and get rid of ho chi
minh
he left the geneva conference after the
first week it's the only time in
american history that a secretary of
state has abandoned a major
international conference right in the
middle
and the reason he did this was because
he understood he was isolated and he
understood that the geneva conference
was going to come to the conclusion that
at least a part of vietnam had to be
turned over to ho chi minh
foster dulles absolutely refused to
accept this he came home and he and alan
immediately launched a large-scale
covert operation
in south vietnam
under the geneva agreements as many of
you know
vietnam was partitioned into a north
north vietnam and south vietnam that
partition was supposed to last two years
and in 1956 there would be an election
in the entire country and whoever won
that
would become the leader of the whole
united country
so the dulles brothers decided to
uh
launch enough covert operations so that
the election of 1956 would wind up
electing somebody that we liked we had
our own
candidate there no denziem and ho chi
minh would then be brushed aside well as
the 1956 elections came close we
realized that wasn't going to work in
fact even president eisenhower said at a
press conference that in this coming
election ho chi minh will win probably
80 of the votes
as a result of this the dulles brothers
and their cat's paw in vietnam diem
decided we're not holding the election
think of this
on the one day
that that one man john foster dulles
flew home from geneva and made that one
decision
we are not going to do what the french
and english and everybody else want to
do we're going to fight in vietnam
without that
there would never have been american
involvement in vietnam at all
the entire vietnam tragedy
is the result of that one decision by
john foster dulles there's no single
individual
more responsible for the origins of
american involvement in vietnam than
foster dallas so that might be the most
titanic uh
black mark in in his history well the
covert operations against ho chi minh
didn't turn out quite so successfully i
think most of you know how that story
ended you can only imagine how our
country and the world
would have been
so different
had foster dulles not taken it upon
himself
to make that
have been choice
that's how different it would have been
uh well you know i'm teaching in
universities now and they tell us that
historians are not supposed to get
involved in counterfactuals but you are
all allowed to do that
um
as they were trying to fight uh ho chi
minh
they turned to another asian leader
president sukarno of
indonesia
they hated sukarno because he
represented the ideology that to them
other than bolshevism was the most
hateful ideology in the world it was
neutralism
foster dulles described neutralism as
fundamentally immoral
he believed that everything in the world
was in the framework of the cold war and
that people like nasa in egypt and
nehru in india and sukarno and indonesia
were hateful figures because they were
trying to destroy the foundation of
conflict that defined the cold war
without which there couldn't be a cold
war
so su carno's desire to keep himself out
of the cold war
led to the dulles brothers deciding to
launch a full-scale civil war in
indonesia i think of all the hidden
stories of the dulles brothers this
might be the most hidden episode we
launched a huge operation
in indonesia aimed at either
overthrowing soucarno or
splitting up indonesia so that at least
some of the islands would come under our
control
that operation failed terribly
but it also sewed some dragon's teeth
about 10 years later in the
mid-1960s the tensions that had begun
festering in indonesia during this
artificially fomented civil war
exploded with terrible violence and
something like a million indonesians
were murdered in that period of
repression in 1965 and 66.
after the
spectacular failure in
indonesia
the brothers moved on to their next
monster
another
neutralist who also seemed unfriendly to
the united states
that was prime minister patrice lumumba
in the congo
lumumba was the first democratically
elected leader of the congo he came into
office immediately after belgium had
granted independence um
he was uh immediately a hateful figure
to the dulles brothers and along with
the belgian colonialists who also
greatly feared lumumba
the cia launched a large-scale
operation to destroy lumumba
president eisenhower actually was
directly involved in
ordering the cia to try to assassinate
lumumba
lumumba was overthrown
and assassinated after less than a year
in power
think about what you've been reading
about the congo in the last few years
this is really the third world war there
are literally millions of deaths in the
congo over the last decade or decade and
a half
the hell into which the congo has fallen
is to a certain degree
the long-term effect of the dulles
brothers intervention there against
lumumba there never was a democratic
election in the congo again
after the one that elected lumumba just
like
in iran and guatemala it wasn't just the
overthrow of an individual but the
destruction of an entire democratic
system
the final monster the dulles brothers
went out against in the world was fidel
castro
that operation didn't turn out too
successfully either
it was
immediately after president kennedy was
elected in 1960 only two days after his
election
that he held a press conference in
hyannisport
and the first announcement that he made
the first sentence that he spoke in his
first press conference as
president-elect was to say that he had
asked alan dulles to stay on as head of
the cia and that alan dulles had agreed
alan dulles then proceeded with the plan
which had already been hatched under the
eisenhower administration to launch the
invasion of the bay of pigs in which
fidel castro would be overthrown
uh
during my research particularly in the
dulles archives at princeton university
i came up with a new take some new facts
about the bay of pigs invasion uh that i
think she had a new light on why that
invasion collapsed so terribly
during the run-up to the
invasion major changes were made in the
plan uh it was decided that the
invaders would land on a beach far away
from mountains the original plan was
they should be near mountains so if they
got in trouble they could escape up into
the mountains
it was decided that
there would only be eight planes
and not enough to take out the castro
air force
and a number of other decisions were
made to restrict the plan
to such a degree
that the two top organizers of the plan
decided eight days beforehand that this
plan is not going to work it will result
as they the words they use in a terrible
disaster now what did they do with this
information
you'd like to think they would have gone
to alan dulles their boss and said
our plan will end in a terrible disaster
but i discovered that alan dulles was
actually not involved at all
in the planning of the bay of pigs
invasion he turned the entire project
over to his deputy richard bissell
and completely absented himself from
planning
he was not present at many of the key
meetings and when he was president he
didn't say anything
uh and i think
i i read all this i was very puzzled
about
why this could be
dulles was not even in washington on the
day of the invasion
he arrived back at the baltimore airport
late that night and an aide picked him
up at the airport and he said so how are
things going
and they'd say well not very well sir
and dollar said oh really
in the eight is then described we take a
ride home dulles invites me in for a
whiskey and we start i try to talk about
cuba but he's not interested he starts
talking about baseball and other things
and not interested in the invasion at
all
i found this very puzzling
but then
i found another piece of this story
uh
it was only a few years later alan
dulles was fired immediately after the
bay of pigs fiasco
that alan dulles was often found
wandering aimlessly in georgetown not
able to find his way home
i found a quote from one of his young
relatives who was his caregiver
who said
i think he was suffering from what we
would today call alzheimer's
i really believe that the reason alan
dulles absented himself completely from
the bay of pig's invasion was that he
was already suffering from the
beginnings of dementia
uh
and that's why these two planners of the
operation went to the deputy they went
to bissell and said it's going to be a
terrible disaster we're cancelling we
don't want to do it and bissell
persuaded them to stay on and sure
enough it was a terrible disaster
john foster dulles
died in office
actually he had resigned a couple of
weeks before but he took ill and died of
cancer in 1959
when he died
the entire nation plunged into grief it
was a huge event
he was a
snarling tough guy that nobody really
liked but when he died he really did
trigger an outbreak of admiration his
funeral was broadcast on national
television
uh alan dulles wasn't so lucky he lived
to see his reputation declined and by
the time he died in 1969
many of the foul early deeds of the cia
were coming to light
so that may have
intensified his slide away from reality
one of the fascinating things about the
dulles brothers
is that as i've said they grew up
together they developed the exact same
way of looking at the world once they
were in office
they never had to consult any experts or
anyone else about their projects
if for example
today an operation were to be planned by
the state department and the cia aimed
at the government of country x maybe
some of the cia experts on country x and
the state department experts on country
x would sit around a table and talk
about whether this was a good idea or
not and how to do it that never happened
during the dulles era all it took was a
wink and a nod between two brothers
they converted american foreign policy
into a an echo chamber that reverberated
with their shared certainties they were
exact ideological twins
but in their personalities they were
total opposites
john foster dulles was dour and s prim
uh mean-spirited i read somewhere even
his friends didn't like him
uh he had a whole series of very awkward
social habits which i cataloged in one
of my favorite paragraphs in this book
at dinner parties he used to like to
peel the
wax off of candles and roll it up into a
ball and then chew on it
um
he loved to stir his old overhaul drink
with his finger and then suck on his
finger
alan dulles was exactly the opposite
allen dulles was like a character out of
the great gatsby he was a sparkling
conversationalist lover of good wine a
great seducer he had a hundred
mistresses from claire booth loose to
the queen of greece uh nobody could
resist his charms
and i think this served the cia very
well because alan dulles was not only
the chief of the invisible government
he was the ambassador of the invisible
government
to the visible government he was always
on the party scene in washington and i
think he was such a nice guy and such a
wonderful fellow that people began to
think well we don't know of what the cia
is doing but if it's such a wonderful
guy doing it it must be okay
so it's remarkable that uh although they
developed
exactly the same politically
they develop very different differently
personally
all of these stories
uh reflect what i said at the beginning
that this book is not just about the
brothers but about
us
it's about who we are
and why we do what we do in the world
i told you at the beginning that uh
we've largely forgotten the dulles
brothers that's my mission with this
book to try to bring them back to life
um
the first step i'd like to take the
dulles brothers bust out of the
conference room at
uh baggage claim number three and bring
it back up to a place where people can
see it in dulles airport
but i have another suggestion
one of the greatest works of political
art of the 20th century is a spectacular
mural by diego rivera called glorious
victory
uh it is a visual depiction of the coup
in guatemala 1954.
so uh
when the coup happened there was an
explosion of anger across latin america
and there were many protest
demonstrations there was a big protest
demonstration in mexico
uh at that time diego rivera was caring
for his wife frida kahlo who was dying
uh she was under doctor's orders not to
leave her bed
after the overthrow of our bins she
insisted on leaving her bed she was
going to march in the protest at the
american embassy to show her repudiation
of the coup against arbenz and you can
actually see pictures of diego rivera
pushing frida kahlo
in her wheelchair it was the last time
frida kahlo was seen in public she died
11 days later
and diego rivera went on to paint this
spectacular masterpiece uh glorious
victory which i reproduce in the book so
the dulles brothers are right in the
middle there's foster dulles with a big
smile
shaking hands with his guatemalan lackey
and alan dulles is right behind him with
a big satchel with dollar bills uh
spilling out of it uh there's a bomb in
front of them that has eisenhower's
smiling face on it
a lot of dead guatemalan children in
front and then in the background
laborers carrying heavy loads of bananas
up onto a ship with an american flag
as i was writing this book
i thought to myself i gotta go see this
painting i've studied it in great detail
on the internet and other reproductions
but
i want to see it in real life
so where is it
i couldn't quite find it i figured must
be in mexico there's a lot of diego
rivera foundations and museums
i was calling one after the other nobody
had it and nobody really knew i actually
had to hire someone in mexico to figure
it out where is it i'm willing to come
to mexico
finally i found out that that mural is
not in mexico it's actually in moscow
in a museum in an art museum there
uh it turns out that diego rivera was a
communist and he sent it to the people
of the soviet union at one point but the
soviets didn't want to display it
because they didn't like diego rivera
for the mexicans he was a communist but
to the communists in moscow he was too
heterodox and open-minded and kind of
anti-soviet sometimes so they didn't
like him either
anyway i found the museum
where the
painting
is hanging and i contacted the
deputy director through a russian friend
of mine and i got back a note i told him
i want to come i'm coming to moscow
and the note came back saying you want
to see the picture hanging here but
unfortunately i have to tell you it's
not hanging here
it's rolled up
on a roll in the basement of our museum
if you want to come to moscow i can take
you into the basement and show you the
role
but i can unroll it because we don't
have any space for that
so what it means is that this
spectacular masterpiece so full of
meaning and so full of a message for us
is
out of sight and who knows
if or when it will ever be seen again
i have a modest proposal for what should
be done with that mural uh it should be
unrolled it should be shown but actually
the audience that needs to see it is not
in russia
i don't even think the audience that
needs to see it is in guatemala the
audience that needs to see it is us that
mural should be in the united states
uh maybe we could make a deal with putin
and see if he'd send it over to us and i
have the exact spot where i want it to
hang i want it to be the centerpiece of
dallas airport with the bust right in
front
so that's my modest proposal uh i'll sit
there and sell books uh in front of the
mural but i think it would be a great
opportunity for americans to contemplate
not only who this airport
was named for
but
who they were
and who we are
because we cannot separate what the
dulles brothers did and who the dulles
brothers were
from what
we have done and and what we are
i repeat they are us we are them they
reflect america and if we want to
understand what america is what america
has been and what america could be
we need to focus on the messages that
the dulles brothers are now giving us
thank you
those who want to ask questions please
there's a microphone
i object to the conflation of your
thesis that they are us and we are they
they represent not us they represented
their clientele at sullivan and cromwell
you describe them as the elite
i need to know why you describe why you
conflate the interest they served which
you described as the elite as they are
us and we are them we are not the elite
we are not the ruling class they are
when they advance their agenda in
vietnam when they advance their agenda
in indonesia when they advance their
agenda in iran when they advanced their
agenda in guatemala they were not
representing us they were representing
their clients their corporate
customers who were investing in the
service provided them by the
by the legal firm of sullivan and
cromwell who were paid mightily
to not represent us but to represent
them
among other things you left out of your
narrative was the collaboration with
nazi intelligence officer reinhard galen
and there lies the problem of what we
face now is that the cia basically is a
nazi organization
okay thank you and you left out the
warren commission
i didn't want to tell you everything
because then there's no reason for you
to buy the book if he was senile in 1961
why did lbj put him on the warren
commission
uh let me let me just make let me just
make two comments about what you said i
think first of all your point about
whether they really are us or not is a
very good one
uh
i
however would like to offer this i think
it's a little too easy
for us as ordinary americans to say well
there's a certain elite of bad people
who do bad things but we're not
responsible for that we're not part of
that they're not really representing us
i i use the word we
uh after
not by accident after consideration
because i think it's important for all
of us to understand uh we are citizens
we are
agents we have the ability
to speak
and therefore it's too easy
to say that a couple of people pushed us
off in a bad direction and no one else
wanted it actually i think the dulles
brothers were reflecting during the
1950s what most americans wanted now did
they want this because of what the media
had told them and what the political
climate was and
because they'd seen so many western
movies about how there's just a few bad
people in town and you need one good man
with a gun to shoot them and everybody's
then happy
you can answer that for yourself but i i
think it's dangerous to try to blame bad
things in the world on just a few bad
people
and as for the collaboration with nazi
germany you're quite right it wasn't
just that uh alan dulles uh hired the
former nazi spymaster galen to be the
essentially the overseer of uh the new
cia spy ring in central europe and in
germany
but in the 1930s john foster dulles was
the principal agent in the united states
for raising money for corporations and
banks uh during the nazi era
he
sold almost 1 billion
worth of bonds for companies in germany
during the nazi era and actually uh
spoke out intensely against american
involvement in that war i have a great
quote from him where he says uh
only fantasy entertains the idea that
germany or japan would ever contemplate
a war against us
and i think he he greatly admired
the nazi regime for two reasons
it seemed to be on good terms with
religious leaders and it also allowed
american corporations to operate freely
that was their definition of a free
country and in that case uh i think john
foster dulles saw the nazi regime as
something that actually was a positive
ally in the anti-bolshevik fight
i want to thank you for writing this
book i think it's a story that needed to
be told i hadn't thought of john foster
dulles for years
and what was their relationship with j
edgar hoover or did they just think he
was a clown because they seemed to be
the only two people in america didn't
have to be afraid of him
uh it's interesting um
both of them had relationships with joe
mccarthy
very different alan dulles refused to
allow the cia officers to testify in
front of mccarthy committee but foster
dulles did he brought in a
an aide to joe mccarthy to launch a big
loyalty purge in the state department as
for um j edgar hoover it's kind of an
interesting story um
hoover at it for a time wanted to be
head of the cia and uh
as you can see in this wonderful new
play called all the way the play about
lyndon johnson
there's an interesting moment uh after
alan dulles was out of office and was
really fading from public life we had
this terrible episode in mississippi
when the three civil rights workers were
killed um
lyndon johnson had trouble motivating
foster uh uh j edgar hoover to go down
and investigate it because
hoover didn't like doing that
um
johnson had to do something
to convince j edgar hoover you better go
down there and launch an operation and
try to track down these murderers how
did he do that he knew
that jay edgar hoover hated alan dulles
and feared him even though allan knowles
at this point was out of office
so he called alan dulles and he said
alan i want you to go down to
mississippi as my personal envoy to
investigate what happened to those civil
rights workers uh and write me a report
about racial tensions in mississippi
alan dela said i don't even know the
name of the governor of mississippi
he had never been involved in the civil
rights issue at all
he did go to mississippi he spent two
days there he wrote a little report that
nobody ever read but the reason he was
sent there was just because lyndon
johnson wanted to stick it to jay edgar
hoover and it worked
thank you
the relationship with him and with the
ig farben the manufacturers of the gas
for death games among other products
what
happened to shaqt he was relatively good
very easy sentence did the dallas
brothers protect him and so to it that
he doesn't get punished in europe back
too much
uh you are referring to the economics
minister in the hitler regime
and he is a figure in this book uh he
and alan dulles work very closely
together in fact they were very similar
types of people they each admired the
culture that had produced each other
both were very
starched uh
uh religiously shaped people at least uh
that's what they would describe
themselves as um
so uh shocked
uh and dulles were the key link
between nazi germany and the united
states during the 1930s
after
the uh
after the war he almight shocked was
brought before the nuremberg tribunal
um
he was found not guilty although uh
chief of the
tribunal uh justice robert jackson wrote
in his decision
that he was the chief figure who lured
the western world into collaborating
with the nazis and there was nobody that
he lured more successfully than john
foster dulles
when it comes to
instances of elite decision making with
regard to foreign policy
often
not always but often
we try to tease out the economic drivers
from
more ideological or national security
concerns
and with regard to
the folks who are the subject of of your
book steve um
how did they get do you think how do you
think they got their head around
them acting on behalf of their former
clients
uh
but also using the government as a tool
for recorded national security concerns
or to put it differently
what if they had not worked for sullivan
and cromwell
um
i know it's hard to deal with
counterfactuals but might their decision
making have been different uh
and also if there were no soviet union
might their decision decisions had have
been different in those cases that you
cited
i like counterfactuals but the dulles
brothers not having worked for sullivan
and cromwell and the soviet union not
having existed it's too far even for me
um
but you actually raise what i think is a
very interesting question that
historians uh of the 1950s have uh
discussed at great length and they've
debated this question
why did the dulles brothers do it did
they
overthrow these governments
in order to defend american corporations
or did they do it because they thought
those governments were security threats
to the united states and leading the way
toward communism
as i've reflected on this i think
there's probably less difference between
those two explanations than you might
think on the surface
but to the extent there's a difference i
come to this conclusion
actually
the dallas brothers did not overthrow
foreign governments to protect the
interests of american corporations they
did it because they felt those
governments were threats to the united
states
but
how did they decide that the governments
were threats to the united states it was
because they were bothering american
corporations so
if the government of country x
never bothers an american corporation it
really doesn't even get onto the radar
screen in washington uh so it's it is
the uh
it's the effort of a government to tax
or regulate or restrict
the operations of an american
corporation uh that is
the
factor
that allowed the dulles brothers to
conclude
that therefore the governments must be
working with the soviets and must be
hostile to us so
i guess you could say they overthrew
governments to protect corporations but
only indirectly the real immediate
reason was they believed these
governments were threats to the united
states
and those government's policies toward
corporate power
were the proofs that they used to
sustain their belief just follow up i
guess the see the unanswered question is
you know one could understand that if
there was some global threat to u.s
economic interests
but in all of these cases we're just
seeing let's say a sector or even a
company within a sector
you know not even being threatened but
perceived to be threatened and you see
how do we make that bridge to
now everybody's at risk versus just this
one flower company what have you i don't
make that bridge but but they did and
i'll tell you how i think they did it
it wasn't just that for example
most of the deck was bothering the
anglo-iranian oil company or that
president arbenz in guatemala was
bothering the united fruit company
something much more profound lay behind
those operations what they were doing is
challenging the entire foundation on
which the world economy was based
the fundamental governing principle of
international commerce was
big corporations in industrialized
countries have to have the right to
extract resources and sell products in
countries uh far away
and they have to be able to do it on the
terms that they set
if small countries have the power
to place whatever restrictions they want
on foreign corporations
the whole edifice of entrepreneurial
global capitalism begins to crumble and
i thought that i think they saw that
they realized that the structure of the
world economy
was going to start to unravel if it
became possible for one country here and
one country there to bother one company
and another company
yeah i'm having trouble
fitting bolivia into this
in bolivia you have a
revolution you have revolution that has
tin
um and
not only and
there's no invasion there's no cohort um
there there is some sort of kind of
cooptation
um where does it fit you you are
absolutely right you sound like an
expert in latin america
i don't think anybody else would know
that but that whole episode is in my
book you're absolutely right let me just
give a little background at the same
time that arbenz was emerging in
guatemala a regime that was actually
more radical was emerging in bolivia and
that came to power as a result of a
violent movement supported by communists
not in an election like in guatemala
and there was a fiery may day speech by
the new president he's nationalizing the
tin industry
by many standards it was a more radical
and more militant regime than guatemala
but we didn't do anything about it and i
i discussed this uh i think this was the
reason
uh it was much it was too hard first of
all uh no coastline you couldn't invade
second of all
no uh country next door that would allow
you to uh set up bases through which you
could invade bolivia
um
also i think they felt that
they didn't have a group within guatem
within bolivia that they could use they
found groups in guatemala in the church
and particularly in the military that
became their cat's paws there was no
such group uh
powerful enough to overthrow a
government in bolivia that the dulles
brothers could use i think they cast
their eyes on bolivia
you know poor bolivia has suffered for
more than a century because they don't
have a coastline but in this case maybe
they were lucky
so you're absolutely right that was an
interesting uh
contrast and i i'll just mention one
other contrast at the same time
that the dulles brothers were deciding
that countries like india and egypt and
indonesia were our bitter enemies
because they were neutralist
foster dulles was actually embracing and
giving aid to the explicitly marxist
leninist government of tito in
yugoslavia
he didn't mind tito i think this the
difference is that
the dulles brothers like all the members
of the foreign policy elite at that time
were immersed in the diplomatic history
of europe they had that's what diplomacy
meant to them all they knew was europe
and they understood deeply all the
permutations of european politics and
they understood where tito fit in
but they knew absolutely nothing about
asia or latin america or africa and they
were not able to distinguish
domestic nationalism
from
kremlin-sponsored subversion in the rest
of the world
hi um eisenhower comes into office on
january 20th
and stalin dies six weeks later on
march 5th
um how did they did you cover in your
book how they responded to that and what
possibilities or challenges they thought
they were facing
i'm going to answer that by telling you
that i think
the dulles brothers as we look back in
them in a cosmic way in history made
three huge
miscalculations
uh the first one had to do with their
relationship with the soviet union
particularly after stalin died
right after stalin died
uh the new leader of the soviet union
malinkov
asked the western leaders for a summit
he wanted to come and meet with the
western leaders
the prime minister of france laniel
loved this idea winston churchill loved
it
foster dulles was absolutely opposed he
believed there should never be any
contact with the soviet union because
just to sit down at a table with them
would suggest that they were rational
creatures and that a deal might be
possible and once you start believing
that
the entire edifice of the cold war could
collapse
so the first huge miscalculation was
their failure to try to engage the
soviet leadership after stalin died as
far as they were concerned and they
actually said this in private
the new regime and people like
khrushchev are actually worse and more
dangerous than stalin because they can
fool the world into thinking that
they're not actually ready to destroy us
the second huge miscalculation that the
dulles brothers made was they completely
misunderstood third world nationalism
uh after the second world war hundreds
of millions of people were emerging from
colonialism and looking for a place in
this turbulent world
the dulles brothers saw them as all
soviet tools they were not able to
harness that um
force of nationalism and try to tie it
to american values which shouldn't have
been that difficult
the third huge miscalculation of the
dulles brothers
was that they had no concept
of what we would today call
blowback
they never imagined that their
operations would have such devastating
effects
years
decades generations later they never
thought that by not holding the election
in 1956 they were setting off a chain of
events in which a million people
including 50 000 americans would be
killed or that they would plunge iran
into decades of tyranny or that they
would send guatemala into this river of
blood in which 200 000 people were
killed or that the congo would descend
into such hellish conflict
their idea was we carry out an operation
after a week it worked
operation's over we're gonna forget it i
guess everybody down there will forget
it and we'll just move on and we'll
never have any other effects so those
are three sins i think for which history
can hold the dulles brothers accountable
uh
i want to take issue with you a little
bit about the bay of pigs invasion
the
books that i read and some quotes and
reports of meetings indicate that
while
richard bissell and i forget the names
of the two gentlemen who were directly
in charge of this assembling the
operation while it's true that they
largely operated independently my
understanding is that john foster that
alan dulles was
uh
fairly well informed and that he became
involved
quite a bit
at the end as the operation
started to unravel a bit
but that the reason it started to
unravel was because
president kennedy began to understand
more about what was going on
and it was
pressure from the white house that made
fewer aircraft available
and that was really the
critical issue that guaranteed the
failure of the operation alan
uh
dulles was very well aware of the fact
that there were
no large forces in cuba that were going
to rise up and support the bay of pigs
he knew that very well he knew that was
complete falsehood
he was instrumental in trying to get the
president to believe that falsehood
and at the end
he was fully aware that only
the
u.s stepping in
after the operation had begun with u.s
air cover
could the
could the
operation succeed
and he was consciously trying to fool
the president and put the president in a
corner so that when the operation was
failing
in order to save face the president
would provide that air cover and the
president refused to provide that air
cover and i would i can understand why
you don't want to go into this perhaps
in your book
but
there's a lot of good literature
on the subject
jfk and the unspeakable why i died and
why it matters one of the best ones
but that
president kennedy was murdered by his
own national security state because he
became a peacemaker in office
and uh
and the earliest pivotal event was uh
the bay of pigs
and alan dulles uh
bore the same kind of a grudge that you
mentioned him
bearing in the beginning regarding iran
in guatemala since he was fired right
after the bay of pigs
and he was one of the people that was
involved in the assassination of the
president and that's why president
johnson put him in charge of the warren
commission because you always want one
of the assassins to be in charge of the
commission
who was also demented well let me let me
say first of all that i have a whole
chapter on the bay of pigs invasion so i
go into everything you say and actually
most of the points you make are
absolutely correct so it was president
kennedy who decided they're not going to
be 16 plans it's only going to be eight
we're not going to be too involved uh
and we don't want to have it we don't
want to have the invasion where we were
planning it because it's going to be too
noisy we got to have it somewhere else
and then
all the newspapers in the united states
started publishing it after they had
already decided it has to stay a secret
otherwise it can't work
so
uh
i think it's true that alan dulles
understood that all this was happening
it is true that he was totally
disconnected from the planning of the
operation
but uh there's a lot of discussion
afterwards so
why did they let it go forward
knowing that all of the key
conditions that they themselves had set
for its success or disappeared
and later on i think we found out the
answer and actually it is exactly the
answer you gave what they believed was
we know this operation isn't going to
work but when it's failing in the last
minute we'll go to kennedy and we'll say
hey we need 25 us aircraft planes and
what's he going to do he can't say no
but he did
and the reason why they believed that
is because the exact same thing had
happened under eisenhower during the
coup in guatemala they had about a half
a dozen planes that they were using
pretending they were rebel rebels from
the guatemalan army they were actually
cia planes three of them collapsed fell
out of the sky suddenly there weren't
enough planes and alan dulles went in
directly to the to the white house and
he went to see eisenhower and he said
uh we gotta have more planes
and eisen and actually the legal advisor
to the state department was in the
meeting too and the legal advisor said
you can't do this this is not legal
you're getting the us government
involved in something you can't do this
and and eisenhower decided in favor of
alan dulles and he later explained which
i think is a classic explanation from a
military man
if at any time you choose the route of
violence or support of violence you must
carry it through to the end whatever it
takes so that was the mindset that not
only the dulles brothers had but that
they thought the white house had well it
did have that mentality while eisenhower
was in the white house they never
imagined that kennedy would say i told
you we're not getting the us air force
involved and i actually mean
it go ahead right there yeah i happened
to meet some of the cubans who were
defending the beaches that day
when i was in helsinki in 1962
and
my theory is
that this whole thing
was an old trick many times played
starting with the way we got the canal
zone
away from columbia where
we fermented this little revolution
inside of colombia and a little
bunch of rebels get a little bit of land
of colombia we come in with the marines
and back them up
the new country of camp panama seeds the
canal zone to us
it's an old trick many times played
and same thing in korea same thing you
know it seems like every country gets
divided in half
well i i'm quite sure what what you say
is right what they thought was that
these uh cuban immigrants
would take a big enough chunk of land
so then
they could declare that as sort of the
free zone and then we could defend their
freedom
against castro and we'd have a foothold
down there and then see what happens
after that right after the invade a few
a few weeks after the invasion um
richard nixon came into the white house
to talk to kennedy and kennedy said to
him what would you have done and he said
just what you did he said i would have
found a way to get a little piece of
land then we would have declared that it
was free cuba and we would have sent
troops in there so you can only imagine
what that would have led to um
but but i believe that uh
those cuban boy scouts had skoda machine
guns
i i feel that uh the the dulles brothers
truly believed
that uh
they the power of the united states in
some kind of a mystic
super irrational way would always
triumph and this is one of the many
themes that i think not only takes you
through the dulles era but it it starts
with before the dulles era as you were
talking about in the early uh 20th
century under teddy roosevelt and it
continued all the way up to now this is
there's this idea that since we're the
united states we're always going to win
in the end but this leads me to an
observation about what's happening right
now just in these weeks in the world so
it hasn't been
very long since the president of the
united states announced that we wanted
to bomb syria
but it didn't work because many
americans were against it and many
members of congress were against it
i can't remember any time in my lifetime
when the united states government wanted
to start a war
and many americans were against it and
then the dulles brothers were also the
number one
promoters of this idea you never talk to
your enemies you never negotiate and
ultimately you get what you want we're
the united states we don't have to
negotiate
we just had the president of the united
states talk to the president of iran on
the phone so it leads me to ask this
question
did the dulles era just end
are we witnessing that if that's true
history is being made right now
thank you very much